Cassius Clay is an MPhil student at the
universe
having completed one year with the
Department
of modern European history and currently
finishing a second year with the history
of art department he majored in art
history at Yale as an undergraduate and
received the paul mellon fellowship to
pursue these graduate studies at
Cambridge clays recent research has
analyzed diplomatic tensions between the
United Kingdom and the United States
over the strategic control of industrial
diamonds during World War two and his
current studies focus on the
intersection of art fashion and
advertising during the interwar period
he's in the process of completing his
dissertation on the British painter
Meredith Frampton a Royal Academy
Academy academician active between
nineteen eighteen and nineteen
forty-five clay has interned at the
museum of fine arts boston as well as at
christie's in the Morgan Library and
Museum in New York he has also worked as
a creative consultant for Kanye West and
as a student guide at the Yale Center
for British art and I think it's pretty
safe to say that these two jobs have
never been used in the same sentence
before welcome Cassius
Thank You Sophie for that introduction
I'm very happy to be back here
especially to have heard from image and
heart yesterday who's the first art
history class I ever took at Yale and
also to be invited back by Tim behringer
who was my supervisor and knows
firsthand how how late my drafts are and
thank you to all of you for coming this
morning and listening to this of
conference papers my paper considers the
political mobilization of pictures and
pictorial organization of facts it's
about war art heartening words and
strategic deployment of information as
both the means of propaganda and an
artistic end in its own right I'll be
focusing this morning on Meredith
frampton's 1943 group portrait of Sir
Ernest Gower's and members of his staff
at the headquarters of the London
regional civil defense control room I
choose it because the painting neatly
distills the abstract chaos of war into
the concrete banalities of civil defense
and the schematic organization of civic
order it is both the glowing endorsement
of the bureaucratic procedure of British
civil servants and a chilling picture of
their sang-hwa when framed within the
historical context of horrifying
casualties and dark uncertainty in the
droning months of the London Blitz the
title of my paper borrows its terms from
plain words a perennial style guide that
sir ernest Gower's or principal sitter
would publish soon after the war was won
and war paint a book published for the
paul mellon center by brian false in
2007 falses book warpaint offers a
valuable service survey of the
activities of the war artists Advisory
Committee which we've heard a bit about
and will abbreviate as the waac it was
an organization headed by Sir Kenneth
Clark during the Second World War to
promote the arts of Britain produced
compelling visual records of the column
licked and to protect a generation of
artists from repeating the cultural
annihilation of the First World War now
rather than take issue with the books
broader arguments or take for granted
the masterful research that it compiles
one objective of this paper is to take a
closer look at falses major contention
that the war artist advisory committees
patronage contributes to a quote
critical evaluation of 20th century
British art as a whole by foregrounding
quote questions of art and self-image
art patronage and links between heart
and society during the Second World War
in general this is a fine conceptual
framework that enables fast to make
satisfying if totalizing statements like
this one he writes the waac laid the
basis for a nationally shared popular
and contemporary culture that not only
bespoke what was touted as a genuinely
British sensibility but also that
stressed the absolute relevance of art
by making it respond directly to the
most cataclysmic event most of the
population would ever know but in
certain episodes of this analysis and
falses inadequate treatment of Frampton
in particular the book makes value
claims about what constituted the most
successful war art in order to justify
the conclusion to its arguments namely
how the waac quote affected the
trajectory of British modernism in the
post-war period for example Faust gives
frampton's decidedly academic painting
short shrift false writes quote
painstakingly calculated images such as
these admirable though they were as
works of art fell short of conveying the
speed violence and unpredictability of
the aerial war itself referring to the
London Blitz this critique misses its
target lobbed without much calibration
and guided by a short-sighted view of
what the Blitz meant to Britain and how
the waac wanted art to reflect it it is
difficult to imagine as false has done
that Frampton ever intended to convey
speed violence or
predictability or that these objectives
were ever put to him by the WA AC which
commissioned this picture even John
Haynes photographic records of civil
defense activity like the scene of an
auxiliary firefighting team hauling
water pumps from a modified taxicab
represent the busy work of clearing
rubble and dousing fires with
diagrammatic clarity and task minded
focus thus I will argue that patients
calm and rational thought were in fact
the primary Civic imperatives
coordinated by the men and women of the
London regional civil defense control
room and that these imperatives informed
frampton's artistic impulses towards the
hyper realistic style through which she
describes them in paint that is to say
Frampton produced an internally coherent
painting whose immaculate factor not
only mirrors the orderly seen that it
represents but actually reflects the
same principles of disciplined resolve
that were demanded of the British people
and that sustains the British nation
throughout the war Frampton's painting
set in a bunker beneath the Natural
History Museum in Kensington registers
the London regional civil defence
control room as a critical nerve center
of the British Home Front in stoic but
unheroic terms echoing sir ernest
Gower's own plain words we withstood to
fully understand what Gower's meant by
this and how Frampton conveyed its sense
in paint some context is required I'll
situate the gaolers portrait within the
body of Frampton serve by examining the
circumstances of its commissioned by the
WA AC I will then go on to discuss some
of the important work done by Gower's as
senior regional commissioner for London
that recommended the distinction of his
portrait being painted and by looking at
other contemporaneous war art and
photographic records I will attempt to
show how frampton's painting was in its
scope how unusual Frampton's painting
was in its scope as well as how usefully
its treatment condenses the significant
forms of resilience into
as we can see memos maps and milk born
in 1894 to the sculptor sir george
frampton and lady Christabel Frampton
Meredith Frampton inherited an artistic
tradition from both parents attended
Royal Academy schools in London became
an associate royal academician in 1934
and a full royal academician in 1942 at
which point he was working on the
Gower's portrait we're looking at today
between the end of the first and the
start of the Second World War Frampton
exhibited at least one painting at the
Royal Academy Summer Exhibition every
year but 1933 these paintings were often
Commission's of intellectual figures in
Britain framed like modern day Saints by
their professional attributes the sum of
the portraits of women are perhaps
better known to us now as they weren't
commissions and entered public
collections more readily rather suddenly
the artist stopped exhibiting after 1945
resigned from the Royal Academy in 1953
and lived in near total seclusion in
Wiltshire with his wife Hilda until
nineteen eighty-four Meredith Frampton
was indeed a man though expectations of
nomenclature could absolve you for
thinking otherwise Isabella Rossellini
did too when she hopped her eponymous
handbag for Leghari in this Frampton
inspired campaign photographed by Annie
Leibovitz I bring up this frivolous
instance of confusion to demonstrate the
ironies that results from an unstudied
approach to frampton's work and its air
SATs afterlife in commercial fashion
advertisements but i think they also
point to a much more serious issues that
turn on questions of residual poor
scholarship and the perpetuation of
inaccurate information because of his
limited output abrupt retirement and a
highly academic style at odds with the
20th century's turned towards
abstraction literature on Frampton has
always been scant and recently stagnant
Richard Moore Fitz catalog introduction
to a 1982 Tate exhibition constitutes
the most complete and current
say on the artist it is 12 pages long I
returned to Frampton's portrait of
Gower's and his staff in order to
demonstrate how small errors in art
criticism can metastasize into
fundamental miss readings of history
Brian false writing in war paint mixes
up the identities of Gower's assisting
staff the middle figure was named as AJ
child when he is in fact kaal Parker
with child to the right in the beige and
the rightmost sitter in the beige was
titled the senior regional commissioner
when that is of course Gower's his
position false locates the setting as
the ARP control room when correspondence
from sparker states that quote there was
no such thing as an ARP control room at
regional level in fact the description
ARP had gone out of use before the date
of the picture and anyway was never used
about regional HQ ARP stood for air raid
precautions which was an organization
folded into civil defense service in
1941 two years before the painting was
finished these mistakes are bad practice
but they also constitute a dangerous
distortion of reality when marshaled in
service of sweeping art historical
pronouncements like falses exaltation of
Paul Nash's Battle of Britain falses
analysis is gratuitous Lee made at the
expense of Frampton using the
verisimilitude of the gaolers portrait
as a foil now false rights of Nash's
painting quote this was exactly the
creative approach to documentation that
transcended meredith Frampton's
obsession with optical detail I will not
engage fauces notion of transcendence
here but I will point out that such a
creative approach to documentation like
the one false deployed in his
misidentification of frampton sitters
their titles and they're setting would
have had little traction in the
documentary and evidential world of the
London regional civil defense control
room both in the initial conception of
Meredith Frampton's Commission and the
eventual construct
of the gaolers portrait approaches to
documentation were precise economical
and considered the war artists Advisory
Committee first discussed frampton's
engagement for two portrait commissions
at the beginning of december 1941 one
sitter was to be nominated by the
ministry of home security this subject
was Serena scours and a second was to be
nominated by the Admiralty that
Commission never came to be as the war
concluded before a suitable subject
could be found the waac contract would
offer Frampton a standard fee of fifty
guineas for a head-and-shoulders
portrait or seventy five guineas for a
half-length rendering but included the
unusual provision of quote additional
payment on delivery of a picture which
has clearly entailed an unusual amount
of work on the part of the artist upon
receiving the remarkable picture of the
Gower's portrait the waac decided to
double the price paid to 150 guineas
frampton's initials response on the
right indicates a commitment to
patriotic service which he foresaw as
possibly impeding the Commission
proposed he wrote that it quote it would
give me great pleasure to accept your
kind suggestion that I should paint two
portraits but as my age is 47 it seems
probable that i shall be called up
almost immediately in the absence of any
definite ruling on this point i think it
would be unwise to start work which
could not be finished frampton who had
already served in france during the
First World War drawing aerial
schematics for trench maps after bonds
would change those lines was referring
to the National Service Prince the
number to act which act which was passed
a few weeks later on December eighteenth
1941 that act extended the age of
national service to sixty including
military service for up to age 51 and
that would cover frampton at age 47
records at the ministry of information
indicates some back and forth in terms
of how explicitly they could tell
Frampton that he would be excused from a
call to service quote am I correct in
thinking it would be in order for me to
tell him in writing
that we can have is calling up deferred
pending his completion of the commission
of painting portraits for us asked one
official ultimately it was decided that
the ministry would ask for his call-up
to be deferred but without a guarantee
and that call up never happened but with
that settled Frampton began work early
in the new year in 1942 but by the
spring of nineteen forty-one forty-two
he had run out of materials needed I
needed to write the Ministry of
Information again in order to obtain
official certification that would allow
the art supplier Winsor and Newton to
release art materials for the Gower's
portrait these communications allow us
to clearance to glimpse the degree to
which resource control impacted daily
life in Britain even in an established
artists pursuit of pigments and brushes
windsor in Newton had to certify the
stocks applied to Frampton and then
receive official permission to replenish
those stocks because of their use for
official purposes complicated by the
fact that the present difficulty with
regards to tubes which were made of
aluminum in demand for myriad other uses
in the war entailed another entanglement
of permits from alternative suppliers
frampton's official correspondence with
the Ministry of Information also gives
us insight into his conscientious
character in the summer of nineteen
forty-two Frampton wrote to the Ministry
that since certifying the paints and the
numbers he required key quote it has
occurred to me that they are only an
estimate of what will be required for
the work I think it a reasonably
accurate forecast but of course there is
the possibility I shall not use it all
if you would prefer me to wait until the
work is finished and thence furnish you
with a definite amount of the materials
used perhaps you would very kindly post
back to me here this earns the bemused
response to the effective don't worry
about it from the Ministry frampton
wrote asking again for an appointment to
submit the painting as it was finished
for censorship in the spring of nineteen
forty three and received a similarly
permissive response that it would be
quote quite impossible for a sensor to
visit the studio
and that quote it may be that a
description of the portrait and its
title will suffice I suspect it was due
to this instruction that Frampton gave
the painting the descriptive specific
and unwieldly title that we grapple with
today it also seems likely that Frampton
deliberately obscured the text on pages
in the Gower's portrait in order to
maintain the principles of censorship as
can be seen from Frampton's 1938
painting of Sir Frederick Hopkins on the
right it was well within frampton's
ability to write out minuscule text in
paint the help goons portrait spells out
lapid offer in which is the pigment in
butterfly wings and below it the related
formula for wavelengths of light
absorption when it hits those pigments
still it is remarkable that the detail
of blurred text in Gower's hand shows it
to be typed rather than handwritten but
it was ours himself who dictated the
unusual addition of two staff members
Kenneth Parker and Lieutenant Colonel
child from left to right Frampton had
only painted one other group portrait of
two sisters two decades earlier in 1923
and the Gores portrait was the larvae
largest canvas he ever produced Kenneth
Parker who served Gower's as deputy
administrative officer described how
Gower's thought it would look quote it
would look ridicul Rahman his own and
Frampton quite rightly wanted him to be
painted against a significant background
so he's adjusted child and me that is
fairly representative figures we might
be posed as what might be described as
supporting players and of course we were
happy to agree it's really pretty
symbolic like Louis the 14th crossing
the Rhine I argue that the symbolic
arrangement described by Parker is
radically different from the historical
antecedent of war art that he cites and
crucially distinct from the nearly
contemporaneous war art of Hitler's
Germany which glad the Fuehrer in armor
and a
full standard it seems likely that
Gower's who had worked in propaganda at
Wellington house in world war one knew
exactly what messages this portrait
ought to convey Frampton would later
write quote I like the person to tell me
exactly what he wants done nowadays the
artist is supposed to be 0 miles above
everybody else and what he says goes but
I don't like that in the Spartan control
room of London regional Civil Defence
Gower's and his staff were plain
civilian clothes they each hold pencils
and papers and Frampton paints them in
the midst of compiling daily reports on
bombings in London as well as
fortnightly reports on the city's levels
of homelessness food water and general
morale Gower's and his staff would have
been in the midst of producing documents
like this one a manual for the disposal
of unexploded bombs this tactical
procedure is signified by Frampton in a
small detail on the lower left side of
the portrait which shows a tally of
roadblocks unexploded high-explosive
bombs unexploded parama she parachute
machines and fires the detail
deliberately addresses a menace known
vividly to the besieged population of
London with deft subtle tea the map of
London shown over Gower's shoulder
situates these types of infant incidents
geographically which enabled them to be
tabulated into assessing the areas
hardest hit the district boundaries give
a macroscopic view of the
micromanagement required to coordinate
the 101 authorities within the one
London region this hierarchy of command
also extended laterally to reconcile
military and civil defense interests for
example a military plan to drain st.
James Park in central London just by
Buckingham Palace and deploy tank
obstacles to impede a potential access
invasion was probably rightly abandoned
because it would have jeopardized London
region's ability to fight fires with
water pumped from that lake
other war artists gravitated to these
types of maps for the formal qualities
of their color blocking and abstract
mass they rendered the same plans quite
differently as spectral sprawls in these
paintings by eric ravilious watercolors
or as dehumanized figurations and
numerical patterns in the more abstract
work of john piper but these data sets
represented real human experiences and
the visual methods of Alec you're
allocating resources to protect them
today they remain visceral evidence of
redeemed calamity as seen in the
superposition of bomb coordinates that
were recorded by Gower staff on today's
maps of West London and East London
frampton skilfully achieves this
connection between objective material
observation and the material objectives
of lives and homes at stake for all the
horrors of combat in battle the
homefront was equally punishing Richard
titmus has observed that the number of
civilians killed by war operations in
Britain outnumbered those of the armed
forces until two years after the war
began it was not until three years after
the outbreak of fighting that the number
of British soldiers killed exceeded that
of British women and children in London
County only one house in town was
undamaged in the London district of
Bermondsey only four houses in 100 were
unaffected by the bombing the detachment
of terms like disposition of reserves
which you can maybe read Phegley in the
kind of blue bands of the table at the
right side of the painting denotes the
number of ambulances in each color
coordinated region these were actually
affixed by personal engagement and
discreet moves of leadership for
instance Gower's was responsible for
amalgamating local fire brigades
throughout the region into a national
fire service that could be centrally
dispatched according to the asymmetrical
bombing of london's districts on nights
of heavy bombing there could be as many
as 1800 discrete fires requiring
agency attention it would be difficult
to overemphasize garras responsibilities
both actively assumed and held in
reserve Gower's oversaw London's air
raid wardens blackout arrangements
firefighting services first-aid rescue
and bomb squads in the wake of bombing
he was responsible for provisioning
evacuated and homeless Londoners with
shelter throughout he organized citizens
labour contributions to the city's civil
defense he was also given provisional
autonomy to lead the London area in case
of invasion and the failure of central
government his letter of appointment
from Churchill read quote if
communication with the government
becomes very difficult or impossible it
may be necessary for you to act on
behalf of the government you will be
entitled to expect all persons to give
you facilities or assistance in
pursuance of their duty to cooperate in
the defense of the realm the centralised
responsibility is borne by Gower's and
his staff depended on the integrity of
infrastructure and a commitment to
preserving systems of regular life on
the ground that could resist bombardment
from above frampton includes three
telephones their lines being part of a
precautionary redundancy to ensure that
if bombing severed one connection
communications could be rerouted through
another the artist also includes a
conspicuous cop in so sir as well as a
fresh bottle of milk a critic writing
for the studio in 1943 after the
paintings exhibition at the Royal
Academy took note of this and complained
that quote any semi heroic portrait
should have an adequate objective climax
and in this case the senior regional
commissioner seems to be depicted in
labor to produce a very realistic milk
bottle this viewpoint ignores the
Herculean efforts required in
maintaining the continuity of something
as simple as milk deliveries to a
capital under siege which required roads
to be repaired railroads to function a
division of manpower to produce a staple
nutrition in
time and rationing to prevent shortages
this much was known to Frampton at the
time of the portraits creation in a
letter to Gower's his wife Frampton
wrote that from the first moment I saw
Sir Ernest I had little doubt about the
final result but I should like you to
know how much I valued his unfailing
patience and sympathetic outlook during
the long process of building up the
picture you can understand that the
atmosphere so created is in itself
inspiring constants within chaos are
powerful things memos maps and milks and
milk are simple staples of stability but
frampton's painting of Gower's and his
staff reminds us more broadly that
official portraiture can operate in
complex in unexpected ways this portrait
of civil defense officials in a bunkered
headquarters explicitly emphasizes the
importance of their systematic work to
keep London running but it implicitly
makes a guarantee of resilience to a
public that should be confident in their
nation's perseverance it also
anticipates a future in which that duty
has been fulfilled it anticipates the
retrospection of our world one made
possible by our data schematics command
structures and sacrifice thank you for
accomplishing that attention with by
considering this painting with me today
you